the Eternals is well underway despite
the fact that the set had to be
evacuated the other day because they
thought they had found any nert bomb hey
everyone its Warren and no need to fear
as it turns out it wasn't actually a
bomb as it turns out it was AC 90 which
is a type of rocket launcher and posed
no threat and the set went back to
working on production immediately after
but that is not the only news that we
have today Galactus himself could be
making an appearance in the Eternals so
I'll talk about this and talk about how
Galactus could actually be turned into a
celestial for the MCU we also have some
leaked set photos of Angelina Jolie as
thena and some leaked set photos of the
actual set as well I'm still doing my
xbox one and ps4 giveaway so be sure to
subscribe to my channel like the video
and leave a comment below so you can
enter so there has been a report and
take this with a grain of salt because
I'll explain where it comes from in a
second that Galactus is going to be in
the Eternals now putting this report
aside this actually makes a lot of sense
because there are many ways that the
Eternals could introduce Galactus we
know that the Celestials are going to be
in the movie which is a great gateway to
introduce the devourer of worlds but
going back to this report it comes from
a random Twitter page that claims to be
on the inside of Marvel Studios and one
of the leaks that they posted not too
long ago on Twitter said Eternals will
feature a cameo from a big purple
character whose name isn't Fanus and
down below there's a hash tag that says
Galactus is coming now of course it's a
random Twitter account it could all be
fake but that's what a lot of people
said about Roger Wardell at first and
almost every one of his leaks came true
but this also isn't their first report
that we've gotten that Galactus could be
introduced in the Eternals MCU cosmic
comm once reported that Galactus is
indeed going to be the next big bat of
the MCU and we could hear about him as
early on as in the Eternals I did a
video the other day talking about how
Galactus his story could be tied into
the MCU and there are actually many
different ways but one possibility is
that Galactus could be made into a
celestial in the MCU and here's why in
the comics there is a celestial known as
exit are the executioner however this
isn't really the name of the celestial
it's more of a title that a celestial
holds now the job of exit are the
executioner is an awful lot like
yes whoever holds this title is
responsible for destroying worlds and
this could have possibly already been
hinted at in the first guardians of the
galaxy and volume 1 the collector shows
the guardians S on the searcher
destroying a planet with the power stone
now since s on the searcher was
destroying the planet it's very possible
that he could have the title of exit are
the executioner at that time and if we
take a look at the staff that he's
holding which holds the power stone
which everybody has been saying for a
very long time now it looks just like
Galactus his head so it's looking like
in the MCU Galactus may start out as a
celestial I don't think that he would
remain this way throughout the MCU I
think there would be an event that
happened that would turn him into the
Galactus that we know now I know some
people won't like this but this is very
similar to what the MCU did with ego
star Lords father ego claimed that he
was a celestial and guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 this is something that they
specifically did for the MCU and there's
a possibility that they could do it for
Galactus as well and as I mentioned we
have some leaked photos from the
Eternals of angelina jolie filming as
her character at thena now she's clearly
in the middle of the desert somewhere so
this could be in reference to Babylon
from the comics possibly or this could
possibly be her searching for the tomb
of the gods
now a lot of people don't really know
too much about the leaked photos but
something that is really interesting is
that these are not the leaked photos
that were used to normally they're very
up close they're clear but the eternal
set has such high security that nobody
can get close and it's one of the most
secretive MCU movies right now if we
take a look at the leaked set photos
this set is all real and shout out to
the Twitter page secrets of Eternals for
posting all of these photos
Chloe Zhou has already stated that she
prefers real sets / CGI sets this movie
is probably going to be one of the
biggest Marvel movies of all time the
production of the movie is going to be
amazing the cast is absolutely stacked
and if they throw Galactus in there this
movie is definitely going to be one of
the greatest MCU films let me know your
thoughts on Galactus and the Eternals
down below also don't forget to
subscribe to my channel like the video
and comment below so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
you